lors de sa venue n'a pas mené comprenez
[Musique]
2003 et j'avais un festival à la
rochelle moi je suis moi je tiens par
qui si on estime que je joue avec la
chorale et après qu'on en finit moi je
reste ici je suis chez eux montés à
paris
eux ils ont venir à ornaisons pris
l'envié de partir j'étais vous jetez moi
je vous rejoindront dans ce schéma n'est
vraiment un m'as dit mohamed et faut
rester ici je dis non je peux pas rester
parce que j j'ai mon école et où j'ai
mes amis j'ai mes parents il m'a même
appelée madiot est resté à rester là bas
ça sans rien demander à ses arrières
descendez qu'est ce que tu vas faire y a
rien en algérie c'est quoi ce que l'on
vient de faire et puis ok j'écoutais je
restais un petit peu dans prêcheur je
suis commencé par tirer un petit peu
dans les métros j'ai regardé les
magiciens ils ont leur musique ils vont
tous nos albums bonfa 2004 deux buts
2005 j'ai décidé achetant sa part
acheter acheter un synthétiseur et
chanter dans le métro pour voir mais
pour tenter ma chance je rends grâce
soit ça passe soit ça casse
shannon
[Musique]
j cl à 10 et ça ça pas beaucoup marché
parce qu'il n'y avait pas beaucoup de
monde
cela dit c'est un petit peu dormir
beaucoup du monde aux frais chez j
fréquenté la laci slaoui t-il à 13 après
je restais sur l'a2 l'a26 populaire en
fait ça traverse belleville ménilmontant
nation ces travaux sont maintenant
partis popularité des riches
[Musique]
en plus je les derniers rendez vous en
pleine nuit c'était à 23,03 entente sera
sais pas ce que vous donnez légion des
bovins troisième en trois autres vidéos
annonce nord moi je travaille demain
ah non
je veux arrêter mais je peux pas te dire
j'ai envie d'arrêter je suis un jour
viendra je vais arrêter
peut-être je pars était peut-être
l'année prochaine tu du pouvoir était
donc je peux me croise me croisent et se
situe
l'état
[Musique]
nous sommes à d'autres et la chapelle
les faits
[Musique]